wake up and make yourself a hardcore
breakfast of skull-shaped eggs to go
along with your death wish
coffee because loot is back if you're
unsure if you have eggs grab one of
these egg minder smartphone connected
trays that let you check your egg level
on the go and even sends alerts when
you're running low don't worry about
overeating with this sugar skull spoon
that reminds you how evil sugar can be
while you're adding it to coffee ends
tea or use it to add caffeine all to
your favorite foods sprinkling it on
your food is like drinking a cup of
coffee so you can finally make energy
pizza if you'd rather just smell food
take a whiff of fried chicken with this
sense of the Commonwealth candle then
set the mood with these star wars mood
lights while you impress everyone and
turn water into wine with this handy kit
that comes with everything you need to
make a bottle of wine in less than three
weeks if you've had too much wine make
sure your kids have this wearable smart
locator called Philip that allows
parents to keep in touch with their kids
on the go with it kids aren't stuck
having to carry around a phone and
parents are able to call or text a watch
to get in touch but if you don't have
any kids just track your pets instead
like my dog Lucy hi Lucy if you feel
more comfortable taking care of
something not living and breathing the
spiri is a programmable flying robot
designed just for you it was recently
funded on Kickstarter and the hope is
that speery can be programmed to be a
reporter cartographer playmate or
inspector ignore electricity with this
pop-out outlet from a door that allows
you to hide your outlets when not in use
by simply popping them in or out if you
prefer natural power try using a hydro B
that powers your USB devices using the
energy and rivers streams faucets or
even while being towed behind a boat
then use it to light up your desk with
this kinetic light Newton's Cradle or
your tail lights circuit stickers are
small flexible circuit boards with a
nice atrophic conductive adhesive on the
back that are compatible with any
conductive material the creators want to
bring electronics and crafts together
giving people the ability to easily
make cool interactive projects or just
use circuits scribe and draw your
circuits instead then relax in your
ridiculously epic skull chair for some
light reading like this book of calculus
for infants for something a little more
grown-up flip through this pop-up book
of phobias that showcase your deepest
fears like snakes spiders dirty toilets
and Heights when you're done reading
your books put them on this balanced
bookshelf that helps you visualize what
you've already read and what you have
left and then really tie the room
together with this monster skin rug
along with your whimsical wobbly
furniture now check your watch and do
some math to figure out what time it is
because we are almost done and all
that's left to do is scream into this
stress reduction shouting base and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
okay Julie